I would like to speak of in love meant
not necessarily the concept of falling
in love with someone although that's a
wonderful sensation but I would like to
talk about this space that's created the
cosmology of two shaped like a heart you
see when you connect with somebody what
emerges is a kind of entrainment through
the act of mirroring each other Yuko
here an intersubjective universe right
it's literally a world inhabited by two
people and that world is impregnated in
real time by a narrative by the story
that we tell ourselves about ourselves
right and we document that story on
social media and we take pictures
vintage sepia-toned photographs to
impregnate the narrative with poignancy
and wistfulness and immediately we
cohere narratives where love prevails
above it all where nothing's gone to
stop us now together we will live
forever we swear to each other we stare
at the iris we stare at our own
reflection in our lovers eyes and we are
reassured we push away all thoughts of
death and we become infinite Alan
Harrington famously wrote in the
immortal list when in love we step off
the people mover carrying everyone else
towards death and instead we become gods
outside of time commingling with one
another inside of eternity Cameron Crowe
the filmmaker famously talks about the
happy sad something he so artfully
captures in his cinema moments of such
sublime beauty and in love meant between
two people it's like being inside a pop
song and living there forever at the end
of Vanilla Sky he said you sculpted your
loose
dream out of the iconography of your
youth a movie you watched late at night
that showed you what love could be like
an album cover that once moved you week
oh here are narratives based on the
cultural impressions of our youth we
live inside of a waking dream
we are the choreographers of our own
love stories our lives are theater and
we willingly metabolize belief we invest
ourselves in our fictions until they
bleed over into the real reductionists
tell us that infatuation and romantic
love are biochemically no different than
cocaine my friends consciousness itself
is mediated by biochemistry to dismiss
romantic love as a spike in dopamine is
to dismiss our entire self as a cocktail
between serotonin dopamine
norepinephrine cortisol whatever the
you want to call it the point is
what emerges rises above its building
blocks right we exceed our materials
Roland Barthes talks about that moment
when you see your beloved the curtain
parts and what had never been seen is
devoured by the eyes it's distinct
abrupt framed it is already a memory the
purpose of a photograph is to
memorialize and to eternalize and when
we have that dance with our beloved we
become fulfilled fulfillment literally
means we exceed totality all of our of
all of our desires are abolished by the
plenitude of their satisfaction and so
we spill over
and why why is love tinged with sadness
then why do we look upon the photographs
of those we love and feel a knot in our
stomach is it a faint disquiet from the
awareness that nothing lasts forever or
does it come from realizing again that
even though we were unstuck in time with
that person living an eternity that
eternity was nonetheless bounded by
mortality on both ends
I refuse to succumb to that defeatist
nihilism I refuse to give up on love no
amount of hurt can ever make me
renunciate my need for salvation and my
willingness to believe that we can
engender salvation in the arms of
another if love is poetry then let us
embrace the poet within us the brave
reckless God's within us all
Miguel de Unamuno wrote in tragic sense
of life eternity eternity that is the
supreme desire nothing is real that is
not eternal and with that we have to
find the strength to prevail